مستقبل الطلاب السودانيين على كف عفريت
اذا
مع دخول اضراب المعلمين هناك شهره هو
الثاني مطالب المعلمين تتصدرها زياده نسبه
الانفاق على التعليم ورفع الحد الادنى
للاجور اولياء الامور في قلق واسطه ما
يصفونه بتعنت الطرفين وزاره التعليم ولجنه
المعلمين والوقت يمضي الى انضاع نحو 30%
من اجمالي الحد الادنى لعدد ايام الدراسه
المعتمده دوليا اي 180 يوما لكن وبحسب
لجنه المعلمين فان الفرصه لا تزال ممكنه
لتعويض ايام الدراسه للتلاميذ متى ما تمت
الاستجابه لمطالبهم لنفهم المزيد مع
الريان الظاهر
تجميد العام الدراسي في السودان شبح يطارد
الطلاب رغم المحاولات المستمره بين وزارتي
التربيه والتعليم والماليه
في الثامن من يناير الماضي اعلن الاف
المعلمين بالمدارس الحكوميه بالسودان
توقفهم عن مهامهم التعليميه بالمدارس حتى
تنفذ مطالبهم وابرزها زياده اجور المعلمين
التي لا تغطي تكاليف المعيشيه موضحين
بدراسه اجرتها اللجنه ان اكثر من 250 الف
معلم بالسودان يعيشون تحت خط الفقر
زياده اجور المعلمين قضيه ليست جديده
وزياده الرواتب شرط وضعته اللجنه لتواصل
عامها الدراسي الذي فقد اكثر من 30% من
المده المتفق عليها عالميا من حقهم يشوفوا
الرواتب بتاعتهم تزيد حسب الاحتياجات
بتاعتهم والوضع العام بتاع البلد الحاجه
الثانيه برضو ما يضربوا لانه هيضيعوا
اجيال جايه يعني والتعليم هو الاساسي يعني
نحن تاخرنا في التعليم شديد دايرين
السودان يتقدم لكن لازم الحياه مع الشاب
يقع صعبه والاساس المفروض يرتب لهم
طلباتهم المعقول يعني المعلم ده من حقه
والله
لو حتى الراتب اللي ياخده هذا
راتب اضعاف راتب اللي ياخده الحمص
في الوقت الذي تواصل فيه المدارس الخاصه
عملها بالسودان يرى البعض ان اضراب
المدارس الحكوميه يؤثروا على الخطط
الدراسيه وربما يؤدي الى تجميد العام
الدراسي حاله استمراره فيما يحذر اخرون من
خطر التسرب المدرسي لصباح العربيه الريان
الظاهر الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
على كل ينضم الينا من الخرطوم سامي الواقع
المتحدث الرسمي باسم لجنه المعلمين
والمعلم التربوي احمد علي ضد الاضراب هو
اهلا بكما معنا ابدى معك سيد سامي من لجنه
المعلمين يعني منذ نحو الشهرين والمدارس
الحكوميه مغلقه بسبب الاضراب لنتحدث عن
اليست هناك مخاوف من تاثير الاضراب على
العام الدراسي وعلى امتحانات الطلاب في
هذه الحاله
سيد سامي السلام عليكم تحيه للمشاهدين
العربيه
يا مرحب بك وتحيه لمشاهدينا العربيه
حقيقه الاضراب هو بالتاكيد في عنده تاثير
كبير على العمليه التعليميه لانه ايام
الدراسه اول يعمل التقويم المدرسي ايام
محسوبه ومعروفه الضياع اي يوم من الايام
بالتاكيد هو عنده تاثير على عمليه
التعليميه لكن
لجنه المعلمين السودانيين والمعلمين لما
بداوا في موضوع الاضراب فما بداوا مباشره
بالاضراب بداوا برفع مذكره يمكن قبل
الاضراب باكثر من 45 يوم اللي هي تحديدا
يوم 16 اكتوبر تم رفع مذكره لمجلس الوزراء
وامانات الحكومات بالولايات المذكره حوت
مجموعه من المطالب وتم انهاء
الحكومه الفتره للرد على المذكره للاسف تم
تجاهل المذكره الى ان اعلن المعلمون يوم 8
او 7 نوفمبر الدخول في الاضراب يوم 28
نوفمبر
يعني لو لاحظتي انه ما بين اعلان الاضراب
والدخول في الاضراب اكثر من ثلاثه اسابيع
فدي كانت كلها فرصه للمخدم لانه يستجيب
لكن للاسف كانت الاستجابه ضعيفه من قبل
الدوله من مضطره
الاضراب المتدرب يعني نحن بهمنا المساله
الانسانيه بالنسبه
للطلبات المعلم وهذه المسؤوليه مسؤوليه
انسانيه تربويه تنشئه جيل وتنشا تعليميه
للاجيال المستقبل الا يعتبر ذلك تنصلا من
هذه المسؤوليه وتخليا على المسؤوليه
الملقاه على كل معلم اليوم في السودان
ماذا بالتلاميذ
بالعكس الاضراب المعلمين كان واحد من
المطالب الاساسيه هو اصلاح العمليه
التعليميه رفع النسبه الانفاق على التعليم
الى عشرين بالمئه وعدم عيار يمكن بيوضع في
كل العالم انه اذا الدوله كانت جاده في
انها تهتم بالعمليه التعليميه لابد من
الانفاق على التعليم والانفاق على التعليم
هو الطريقه الوحيد لاصلاح العمليه
التعليميه في السودان المنهاره
البيشهد عليه انهيار يمكن كل الدلائل تشير
الى المساله دي فبالتالي
المعلمون لما اضربوا يمكن كان اول مطلب
تناسى المعلمون يعني كل المطالب الذاتيه
في البدايه
واعلنوا انه اول مطلب لهم هو زياده
الانفاق على التعليم فبالتالي ده بياكد
انه المعلمين ما كانوا حريصين عليه
حقوقهم فقط انما هم ايضا حريصين على
العمليه التعليميه لكن تسال الدوله بص وره
مباشره عن ما يدور الان طيب نفكر في
الطلاب اولا مع اقتراب امتحانات شهاده
السودانيه حتى اليوم الطلاب فقدوا 30% من
عامهم الدراسي من ايام عامهم الدراسي هل
سيعاد النظر في التقويم الدراسي هل يتم هل
سينجح المعلمون في تعويض الطلاب عن ايامهم
التي راحت بسبب الاطراف
انا بفتكر انه اذا تم حل المشكله
التعويض ممكن ما في مشكله المعلمين جاهزين
لانه ممكن يعوضوا ما فات اذا وزاره
التربيه والتعليم لانه ايضا تمديد العمل
الدراسي هو مسئوليه الحكومه بصوره مباشر
اللي هي وزاره التربيه والتعليم
فنحن كمعلمين ما عندنا مشكله اذا تم
الاستجابه للمطالب ما في مشكله اذا تم
تمديد العام الدراسي والحاجه دي ممكنه
وحصلت قبل كده في ايام الكورونا تمديد
العام الدراسي لكنه مفتقر انه الاولويه
الان ينبغي ان تكون لمعالجه المشكله اللي
ادت الى الاضراب
طيب يبدو انه استاذ احمد مش معنا هل
تسمعني
اهلا اهلا بك معنا يعني للاسف يعني وصلت
متاخرا على الهواء مباشره حتى ندخل في هذا
النقاش والجدل مع الاضراب وضد الاضراب
ولكن لماذا لم تستجب الدوله حتى الان
والقياده لمطالب المعلمين او اظهار حتى
مرونه في الحلول المطروحه
طيب بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
والله انا افتكر انه المعلمين لديهم
يمكن قضيه عادله
والاضراب هي
للمعلم لتحسين وضعه ولكن ايضا العام
الدراسي
مربوط بتقويم
ومربوط بمسؤوليه كبيره جدا تجاه هؤلاء
التلاميذ فيجب الموازنه بين بين بين
تعطيل العام الدراسي وبين مطالب المعلمين
انا بفتكر انه الاضراب يمكن ناجح جزئيا ما
ناجح كامل
الجزئيا وممكن نجاح يكون في في مدارس
الثانيه منا نحن
عندنا
بياخذ
شكل المحاضره يعني يومين في الاسبوع
ومعلمه الاساس من الصباح
بعد اخر التلميذ يعني
الاولويه
الغاز العام الدراسي
وعدم ضياع الاديان
على الدوله ان
تنفذ مطالب المعلمين
والمطالب دي يمكن هي الان مطالب ما اصبحت
حقوق عشان احنا نعطل بها العام الدراسي
يعني هي
اخواننا في لجنه المعلمين
يعني اصبتوا لهذه المطالب ويمكن قاعده
المعلمين العريضه منقسمه يعني ما اقول لهم
مع الاضراب ولا اقول لهم لجنه المعلمين
يعني
نعم طيب احنا بنشكركم جزيل الشكر وعلى هذه
المداخله ولكن انتهى الوقت المعلم
والتربوي احمد علي وايضا نشكر ضيفنا من
الخرطوم ما سامي باقي المتحدث الرسمي باسم
لجنه المعلمين شكرا لكما